uh you guys remember massive dumps no no
I'm not talking about those of you who
have little babies at home I'm talking
about this phrase that Donald Trump
started using to Signal fraud in 2020
that there were dumps of ballots
seemingly without even a hint of
understanding the Absurd and ironic
nature of that phrase just moments
before the Arizona gubernatorial race
was called against Carey lake lake
appeared on Fox news with Jesse Waters
and again without like a shred of
self-awareness of how stupid they sound
talking about these dumps
they started talking about dumps listen
to this
what's gonna happen when we hear about
this vote dump in about I don't know
minutes it could be Carrie I I don't
know we know we think we should be in
good shape yeah we think it's going to
be a pretty favorable dump
Maricopa County where they took our
sacred vote and they and they just made
a mockery of it they dumped all over the
boat rage is Jesse what happened I had a
man come up to me at breakfast yesterday
he had tears in his eyes no sorry I said
I showed up to vote there was a
three-hour line they said the tabulator
machines were not working I drove across
the way and went to another 15-minute
drive to another Center and the printing
uh printers weren't working they had no
toner in them I drove another 20 minutes
and finally voted it was a half a day
Odyssey to cast my vote and we're
getting thousands of people reaching out
saying the exact same thing we don't
know how many people just finally gave
up because it was so hard to vote and
when they did get to the front of the
line only to find out the tabulator
wasn't going to count their vote it was
all right so anyway she's going on about
things going Beyond just dumps at this
point in time remember that every one of
the claims that she made was either
refuted or explained there was an issue
with the tabulator the only person that
was going around saying leave this
polling place and go to a different one
to have your vote counted were
Republicans in support of Kerry Lake
that was a self-inflicted blunder the
election officials from Maricopa County
who by the way are Republicans came out
and said listen there was an issue with
a with a tabulator we fixed the issue
everything's fine and of course they are
relying on Old tropes in this case the
infamous massive dumps quote just
because you hear dumps doesn't mean
anything was stolen but remember this
iconic moment from failed former
president Donald Trump and what happened
if you watched the election I was called
by the biggest people uh saying
congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and I'm sure you
felt that way right this election was
over and then they did dumps they call
them dumps big massive dumps in Michigan
and Pennsylvania yeah and the Maria
Bartiromo moment where she adjusts her
glasses As Trump repeats that there were
dumb is really just uh it's I believe
it's one of the most important moments
in political media History of the United
States all right so they went the route
of the dumps and the dumps were not in
their favor and Carrie Lake lost I love
cooking at home I cook all the time
having a good set of knives that you
actually like to use is really important
for years I have been a fan of the
advantages that Japanese knives offer
and our sponsor kamikoto makes amazing
Japanese steel kitchen knives using the
traditional techniques that date back to
the Edo period of Japan kamikoto only
uses steel from Japan each blade takes
years to craft and goes through a
rigorous 19-step inspection process with
a lifetime guarantee the knives come in
a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood box
makes it a really great gift easy to
store as well on the kamikoto website
you can see a map of the Michelin star
chefs all over the world using kamikoto
knives my kamikoto knives at home have
been performing great for years you
really just can't beat the feel of a
nice Japanese knife perfectly balanced
in your hand and kamikoto is now running
a big Black Friday sale my audience gets
an extra fifty dollars off go to
kamikodo.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below